[Music]
hi reject nation Greg Alba here John
humph so on patreon one of our reward
tiers is whatever video you request you
must definitely do a good friend of ours
who has also become one of our top
patrons it's nice to have friends like
that who pledge a lot of money Jason
Dolan who was a screenwriter for the
film vanishing of sitting I'll actually
read a screenplay of his vampire flick
he wrote and is really cool I was
genuinely surprised when you live in LA
you'd be us a lot of people and that was
one where I'm like you know I really did
enjoy
I found myself up all night reading it
as opposed to I'm gonna take there's ten
pages a day breeze through it
Jason Dolan his video request is
something that no patrons ever requested
before trailers revisited for a film
that we fortunately watched again a few
days yeah JT in April dawn perfect time
to request this buddy if you guys are
know what trailers revisited it is on
this channel look at a trailer for a
movie we've already seen you know since
trailers are such a big part of our
lives and relationship between marketing
and movies is such a big talk we like to
determine how accurately portrayed was
the movie based off its trailer yeah
trailers revisited for Mission
Impossible the first one because I don't
remember the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm chasing after they came come to
those find something that's personally
wait I remember they made out with John
points boy
[Music]
we should watch him on the Today Show
with Matt Lauer that's right they reel
he survives that yeah I gotta take this
back a little bit and find that moment
cuz I want to make sure I didn't miss
see that that's totally a deleted seat
that's not in a movie remember there's
one scene where she like kisses his hand
and it's like flat-out not included in
the movie scene now I'm just gonna be
speculative why they cut that scene out
you know some American audiences
couldn't handle something like that back
in the 90s man I don't know if you guys
remember the movie that well but on the
train he's trying to figure out is she
working with John Boy yeah and then he
figures it out and he's all kind of
disappointed in the situation course but
the way he plays it out if they have
this scene I kind of wouldn't have
accepted his reaction to him finding out
it's more of like oh man that's a bummer
yeah thank God I had sex with you the
day before Sam and they do it looks like
it's from that moment that adds an extra
layer of context but he was suspicious
of her and they established that I think
that boy would make Ethan Hunt look a
little bad I'm sure the intent was make
her look worse by doing this so the
traitor effect is even heavier because
she led him on I think Ethan Hunt
suspecting and knowing John Boyd's alive
unless that occurred before he finds out
John Boyd's alive treszura visited
became a whole other thing here I like
the trailer I what I find fascinating
about the theme song versus the movies
there's only one movie I feel that truly
matches the theme song part two part two
man that slow ass movie only gets cool
like part four ghost Protocol is not my
favorite Mission Impossible movie but if
there's one that feels like the theme
song throughout it's that movie
most like rollicking adventure that's
the most fun yeah this because this one
is a dark spy hardcore Brian DePalma
film yeah and I had forgotten just how
much it's that until we watched it again
I was surprised we were watching it that
this is kind of a menacing feeling yeah
there is a foreboding sense and it's
more grounded than you associate Mission
Impossible with even though they do do
do-do-do do-do-do some outlandish things
you know yeah yeah they do some
outlandish things but it is more
grounded it's it's less on action
sequences there's something like
thrilling and fun about that theme music
that just isn't yeah the same tone cuz I
think when it occurs in the movie it's
cool but I can only remember one
specific scene where it really played an
effect and that's when he's on the
helicopter yeah that moment worked
really well and does garner some serious
nib chills when I'm watching this
trailer I'm looking at these images
yeah the theme doesn't match with those
actual scenes they're who because it's
really a berries kind of it suspenseful
and liberabit and one of those spy
movies where you really have to pay
attention yeah it's gonna be very
confusing the NOC list I had to ask a
few times with a group of what's going
on because I'm kind of used to three
four and five stunts are complicated but
where's this one the spy stuff is very
hard and so the trailer is smart because
it capitalizes on the intensity of cool
sequences that they keep cutting around
you know like Tim falling the times a
run there's fish tank blowing up the
helicopter sequence is the train
sequence it's really cool it's not a
spoiler trailer which is neat no I mean
from just an editing point of view it's
interesting to look at this as compared
to what we get now because this is just
like a lot of fast edits just showing
you a whole bunch of different moments
highlighting most of the action the
intrigue the espionage yeah and you
don't get a whole lot of like scenes
stuff they don't reveal the most
upsetting part of the movie for Mission
Impossible TV show fans they all die
wipe out the cast because the Tom Cruise
movie it doesn't feel like a true team
movie until ghost Protocol all these are
based off of him going road that IMF
would
learn to trust it usually has a helping
hand you know being reims is usually
there simon pegg shows up mi3 has some
help but even then it still feels like a
Tom Cruise vehicle but Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol is one you
feel the ensemble this have more of a
spy knew or thriller feel and that's not
really conveyed in this trailer they
kind of make it look like a modern-day
bomb on day four the 90s bond yeah well
that's kind of how I remember the
argument being at the time it's like
James Bond or Mission Impossible and
like looking back they're kind of trying
to do different things I mean there's a
certain element of like future tech in
Mission Impossible but I feel like it's
different from James Bond's very
different I mean Tambor's different I
think it's more clever I think in terms
of conveying the tone of the movie it
does a pretty good job
I think the first 30 seconds of this
trailer worth it's actually like all
quiet there's no music in the background
is a unique for a trailer and be it's
for a movie feels like in the first
half-hour yeah feels like it's gonna
take its time and be minute does
deliberate film I think the film is not
as snappy or as like fun because when
the movie gets dark and the twists occur
it does have this kind of sinister
undertone yeah that is a little
surprising especially we hear this theme
song and what the franchise has become
the last thing you really associate with
is that sinister undertone but that's
where the Brian DePalma touch comes in
yeah and I feel like that's kind of a
nice thing to make this particular movie
this installment distinct because like
watching it back to the limitations of
what was available to them in the 90s
kind of made for the perfect scope I
think it's interesting that you have a
lot of images from the movie overall but
it doesn't feel like it's spoiling stuff
because they're so mixed up and they're
mostly just hinting with little lines of
dialogue at mistakes there's gonna be
like a betrayal of some point or
double-cross at some point ya know
they're basically just leading with the
tension like exactly because I think the
writing and not that this is was to be a
review of Mission Impossible but I just
want to say I think the writing of this
one in some ways is some of the most
clever out of the franchise it's the
most of just a spy movie without the
extra like crazy set pieces and bells it
was because when you think of the famous
stunt where he's hanging that stunt is
like compared to what he does now
and a big deal when you watch the movie
it's intense
it is because of how they set up what he
has to do that when I watch it I am
there going wow this really is a scary
situation where like everything is
designed to protect you I mean now he
has like fall out of the sky but in that
movie he's like he has to catch his
sweat well yeah it turns small stakes is
a huge stakes yeah I think it really is
fascinating to go back and re-examine
not just this trailer but go back and
re-examine the movie because it adds
even more layers to Wow look at the
evolution yeah this franchise that's
that's the biggest impression that I'm
watching gonna get left on me his name
Wow things have changed over since 1996
yeah and like this was still a good
iteration of what this could be even
though it's grown into something yeah
find it different and I feel like
Christopher McQuarrie is kind of been
bringing it back to something like this
yeah like a combination of what the
ghost Protocol and mi3 introduced right
now this was fun thanks for requesting
this Jason don't because this this was
fun is cool to check out this trailer
what's your favorite Mission Impossible
movie put it in the comments wall and
explain why also leave some requests for
trailers revisited love to hear your
guys thoughts you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation hey click that
notification Belka subscribe buttons are
essentially broken you can check us out
on patreon full light evey show
reactions weekly q and A's music video
covers would love to have you become a
patron ejecta today